let's explore another mechanism that we
can have with a ketone and actually an
aldehyde could undergo a very similar
actually the same type of reaction so
let's say that i had a ketone that
looked like this
that's my
draw my carbonyl group just like that
and then it is bonded to a carbon that
is bonded to two other ch3 groups and
just to make it clear i mean there's
three hydrogens off of this carbon there
implicitly but i'm going to draw the
fourth bond here which is to a hydrogen
because this hydrogen
is going to be important for this
reaction now we know that the oxygen has
two lone pairs of electrons let me draw
it up here and let's just imagine it's
floating around in some water and we
know that in water there is some
concentration of hydronium and let's say
that one of the hydroniums is right over
here
so let's see hydronium is just a
positively charged so this right here
let me make it clear
this let me do a different color
this is what water looks like
this is what water looks like and if
water gives away an electron to a proton
it looks it looks like this it is
hydronium and it only has one lone pair
of electrons it gave away one of the
other pair one of the other electrons
and its other lone pair to a proton so
you could imagine a reality well it's
like hey i could grab that proton from
this hydronium and then this will turn
back into water and in that situation
the mechanism would look like this
this electron let me do it in a
different color
this blue electron
gets given to this
this proton if they just bump into each
other just right and then the hydrogen's
electron gets taken back
by what will become a water molecule so
if that happens what do our molecules
now look like
so now our what was a ketone looks a
little bit different than a ketone
so it looks like this i changed it to a
slightly lighter color of green
so it looks like that we have our lone
pair over here but we no longer have
this lone pair at this end we still have
this magenta electron but now it is in a
covalent bond with the blue electron
which was now given to the hydrogen
proton let me scroll up a little bit
it was given to
this hydrogen proton up here
it was given to that hydrogen proton up
here and then this hydronium molecule it
took back an electron and now it is just
neutral water
it is just
it is now just neutral water took back
that magenta electron so now it has two
lone pairs again
so it is just neutral water now this
since this oxygen up here in the
carbonyl group gave away an electron it
now has a positive charge
it now has a positive charge but this is
actually resonance stabilized you could
see that this is or you could maybe see
that this would be in resonance or
another resonance form of this would be
would be if this guy's positive so he
wants to gain an electron so maybe he
takes an electron
from this carbon the carbon in the
carbonyl group right over there so if he
takes that electron so then the other
resonance form would look like this you
would have and let me do the same colors
you have
now only a single bond with this oxygen
up here
this carbon down here still bonded to
the same carbons and then this carbon
over here we could call this an alpha
carbon this is an alpha carbon to the
carbonyl group it still has a hydrogen
on it right over there and this oxygen
since it gained this magenta electron so
now it has two lone pairs again it has
this pair over there and then it gained
it has this electron and this electron
so it has another lone pair and of
course it has the bond to the hydrogen
it has the bond to the hydrogen since it
gained an electron it is now neutral
this carbon lost an electron so now it
is positive
so now
this carbon
this carbon right over here is positive
and these two are two different
resonance forms so they help stabilize
each other and the reality is actually
someplace in between and i can actually
draw it in brackets to show that these
are two
resonance structures
now you can imagine just as likely and
actually i shouldn't just draw this as a
one-way arrow because this guy could
take a hydrogen from this hydronium or
the or a water could take a hydrogen
from this guy so this actually could go
into in both directions let me make that
clear
this could go in both directions
you could say that they're in
equilibrium with each other that you're
just as likely to go in that direction
as you really for the most part are to
go in the other direction but you can
now imagine okay this is now turned in
from a carbonyl group this is now a
hydro this is now an oh group this is
now turned into an alcohol although we
have this carbocation here that this
does not like being positive and so you
can you can imagine where this electron
right here being attract on this
hydrogen nucleus might want to go really
bad to this carbo cation and it just
needs something to nab the proton off
for it to go there and the perfect
candidate for that would just be a water
molecule we have this water floating
around so let me draw another water
molecule just like this
it has two
lone pairs it can act as a weak base it
can give one of its electrons to this
hydrogen proton if it does that at the
exact same time bumps into it in the
exact same way
this electron can then go
to the carbocation and if that happened
if that happened and
you could go in either direction this
this reaction is just as likely to
happen as the reverse reaction so we
could put this in equilibrium
we could put this in equilibrium but if
that were to happen then what started
off as our ketone now looks like this
it now looks like this we have a bond to
an o h group
to an oh group
just like this and over here actually
let me draw the rest of it
we had our molecule it looked like that
but now this electron gets given back to
this carbocation we now have a double
bond here between between our between
our carbonyl carbon or what was a
carbonyl carbon and our alpha carbon so
now we have this double bond
right over here
we have this double bond right over here
that hydrogen has been taken by the
water and now that is hydronium so let
me draw the water or the hydronium
so that water
it had that one lone pair and then the
other lone pair got broken up because it
gave one of the electrons to this
hydrogen right over here and it went
back to being hydronium so what happened
here we started with a ketone
we started with a ketone
and we sometimes will call this the keto
form of the molecule and then we ended
up with something called the enol form
an enol or maybe an in yeah i should say
you know or enol form an enol comes from
the fact that it is an alkene
alkene it is an alkene that is also an
alcohol you could even call it an
alkanol it has a double bond and on one
of the carbons that has a double bond it
has an o h group and the whole reason i
show you this mechanism is one just to
show you a mechanism that could happen
with an aldehyde or ketone this was a
ketone but if this was a hydrogen right
here this would have been occurring with
an aldehyde
but even more this is a pretty common
mechanism that you'll see in organic
chemistry classes and actually has a lot
of functions in biology in general and
these two molecules these two molecules
this ketone and this enol form these are
called tautomers
these are called tautomers
these are called tautomers and the keto
form is actually the much more stable
form you'll in a solution you'll you
won't see much of the enol form but
these can occur it can spontaneously
through equilibrium get to the actual
enol form and so you could imagine these
are tautomers so this mechanism is
actually called a tautomerization and
these are the keto and enol forms of the
tautomers